as we count down to earth day this
friday cbs news is launching our earth
365 series it's focusing on issues
affecting the health of our planet year
round the latest u.n climate report
warns that the world needs to move very
quickly away from planet-warming fossil
fuels like coal oil and natural gas
stuff a lot of us use the idea is to
switch to cleaner forms of energy like
wind and solar power which are now
cheaper and more abundant than ever
before but to ditch fossil fuels rapidly
a lot of experts and even some
environmentalists say we also need to
consider the nuclear option senior
national and environmental correspondent
ben tracy visited america's first new
reactors in more than 30 years and
learned that nuclear power could be
poised for a comeback
and so this thing that's the new reactor
that is
that's it that is the newest nuclear
reactor in the united states there's two
of them being built here outside augusta
georgia when combined with these other
reactors built in the 1980s this will be
the largest nuclear power plant in u.s
history we're building the future of
energy and we think nuclear power is a
major part of it chris womack runs the
georgia power company which is
overseeing the final construction of the
first nuclear reactors in the country in
more than three decades it's taken 10
years and costs more than 28 billion
dollars so that is nuclear fuel in there
that is nuclear fuel there he showed us
this 47 foot deep sapphire pool loaded
with nuclear fuel rods containing
uranium that will enter the reactor and
power a million homes why do we need
this our customers need energy on a 24 7
basis there needs to be a foundation of
our electric grid that's available all
the time
right now that foundation is fossil
fuels which are rapidly warming the
planet
causing devastating and deadly changes
to the climate
coal oil and natural gas make up 61
percent of our energy supply in the u.s
renewables such as wind and solar are 20
percent and the nation's 56 nuclear
plants make up the rest nuclear power
creates no planet warming emissions and
when the wind isn't blowing and the sun
isn't shining the atoms are still
splitting it's reliable
it's safe it's affordable and it's very
very clean if this is such a great form
of power generation why are these the
only two reactors being built in the
country you know we got away from it
[Applause]
because the public turned against it in
the 1970s concerns over nuclear waste
and security fueled a nuclear power
backlash you have a serious condition
you get everybody into safety areas and
make sure that they stay there the 1979
film the china syndrome stoked fears
with a fictional meltdown at a nuclear
power plant 12 days after it hit
theaters radioactive xenon gas is still
being discharged life imitated art in
pennsylvania at the 3 mile island
nuclear facility no one was killed but
then came 1986. u.s officials believe
the disaster at chernobyl began on
friday the meltdown of reactor 4 at
chernobyl in ukraine when it was part of
the soviet union became the worst
nuclear disaster in history
directly killing 31 people and exposing
millions more to the fallout these
accidents made nuclear power itself
radioactive nuclear power
is dead it died at three mile island
dozens of planned nuclear projects were
canceled and the u.s doubled down on
fossil fuels but now nuclear power is
once again making headlines as a way to
potentially save the world from climate
change electricity demand in the united
states and really all around the world
is only going up up up up up alex
trembath is deputy director of the
breakthrough institute a climate think
tank he says to electrify everything
from our vehicles to our homes and
businesses we will need nuclear there's
no grid on the planet that relies
overwhelmingly on wind and solar for
more than even half of its electricity
generation so everywhere in the world
where nuclear gets shut down it's
replaced largely by fossil fuels
after the 2011 meltdown of japan's
fukushima daiichi nuclear plant the
japanese and the germans shut down most
of their nuclear power coal and gas
filled much of the void the u.s is on
track to decommission nine nuclear power
units in just eight years including
california's diablo canyon plant which
generates 10 percent of the state's
electricity far more than wind power
provides i don't know why we would we
would take this enormous piece of our of
our clean electricity pie and just throw
it in the garbage trembath argues the
impacts of fossil fuels are killing far
more people than nuclear power ever has
and nearly 80 scientists in academics
recently signed a letter urging
california's governor to keep diablo
canyon open warning that closing it is
irresponsible and potentially
catastrophic nuclear power has been
getting its shot in the united states
for at least five decades ralph
cavanaugh is with the natural resources
defense council he argues nuclear is too
costly and takes too long to build to
effectively help fight climate change
and there's also that other issue our
failure to find a nuclear waste solution
which means that any community that
hosts a nuclear power plant has to be
prepared to
also host its radioactive waste for
centuries if not longer the nuclear
industry is now touting a next
generation of smaller safer and less
expensive plants
bill gates is funding a company called
terra power which plans to build its
first compact nuclear plant in wyoming i
think people can come around chris
womack says he's excited to show that
nuclear power has a future despite being
billions over budget nuclear power will
be reliable stable fuel source for many
many years to come in what could be a
new atomic age
for cbs mornings i'm ben tracy in
waynesboro georgia
well something for everybody to mull
over i think mr womack and mr trimbath
make some really interesting points
about nuclear but a lot of people are
still holding on to those movies the
china syndrome yeah then in the early
80s it was uh the day after yeah i
remember that as a kid that was
every child
yeah i think there still needs to be a
re-education on nuclear energy yes but
hearing tracy being told it's reliable
safe affordable and clean right it does
help put people at ease and that point
that you know fossil fuels are killing
far more people than that
right has i mean i live in france 70 or
two-thirds of france's energy comes from
nuclear power there are ways to do it
properly there are ways to do it so that
you don't see the things that we saw in
chernobyl or even three mile island
that's right